contact bearing 0 91 range and definite
most likely to you both sir the Battle
of the Atlantic is everything that
happened in the Atlantic Ocean from the
moment World War 2 began there were
thousands of ships that were operating
at any given moment trying to make the
perilous journey from the Western
Hemisphere to Britain sending what was
needed to liberate Europe they were all
would be targets of the Nazi submarines
puffed-up reports the German
transmission bearing zero eight seven
degrees range one five two two zero
miles these convoys would have to make
long zigzagging courses hopefully
avoiding the submarines but they were
reduced to the speed of the slowest ship
in the convoy and the Nazi submarines
were just as fast when they were on the
surface combat looks like our friends
come up for fresh air it's a maintain
speed with us contact bearing two zero
seven range three miles
early in the war the American ships had
radar they could see what was on the
surface but it was a spotty radar it
often didn't work very well told us I
don't know sir I can't get a good read
so you're relying on your eyes much like
a guy with binoculars on the bridge with
sonar and hydrophones relying on your
ears got'em spots that close dr. Dean
0-8
come on and all those things can play
tricks with you over time
still stationary possible decoy reports
contact is not moving possible decoy yet
another challenge was how primitive
communication was between parts of the
ship to the captain Hans had been sent a
curry starboard 0 1 to arrange 600 yards
surf mr. Lopez stand by with a medium
pattern Menon ready sir
it was the guys job to repeat what they
just heard to the captain or repeat what
the captain just told them to whoever
he's talking to and it has to be exact
contact now best port 0 1 2 close you're
gonna do that again no sir if so you
will be relieved ideally a convoy goes
across the ocean without ever talking to
anybody but themselves any radio signal
going from the convoy to headquarters
you didn't want to send those out
because if anybody was listening they
know where you work well I break radio
silence with a message to the Admiralty
every ship was on their own
there have been movies about world war
two but we expanded it embracing the
details but at the same time tying those
details into the human story what do we
rely on in order to get us through this
will bring hell down from on high our
movie puts a magnifying glass on the
history of the Battle of the Atlantic
there they come
you
you